lizards Diablo 2 isn't the only classic
game the company continues to update I'm
Dave and welcome to your GameSpot news
update the studio announced that is
planning to launch a new update this
coming week for 2002 s Warcraft 3
Blizzard classic games lead Robert
Bryden Becker made the announcement in a
YouTube video posted today by back to
Warcraft the video is themed around the
Chinese version of Warcraft 3 but Brydon
Beckett explains that the update 1.27
will be released around the world on
March 15th thank you very much for the
support over the past decade playing
Warcraft 3 over the past few months you
may have noticed we have introduced a
new battle platform it's introduced
features like matchmaking and the
ability to communicate with your friends
at a level that is unparalleled to
anything we could have done with
Warcraft 3 in the market before and on
top of that we're proud to announce that
on March 15th the next patch for
Warcraft 3 will be available in the
market simultaneously with the rest of
the globe at this point Blizzard isn't
saying what's included in the patch back
to Warcraft suggests in their follow up
video that the patch may include balance
tweaks but this is not confirmed
Brydon Becker also teased in the video
that Warcraft threes upcoming patch
won't be the last as Blizzard is
planning more updates of unspecified
nature for the future
see abilities patch the first in almost
five years introduced changes to help
the game run better on modern computers
it's possible Warcraft threes will do
the same these updates for all Blizzard
games comes after the company formed
classic games division last year at the
time Blizzard had said we need engineers
to help maintain our legacy games we
have a history of maintaining our games
for many years our earlier games are
still played and enjoy today so we want
to continue to maintain them for those
communities so you still play these old
classics all the updates make you dig
out your old CD ROMs let us know in the
comments section below or find me on
twitter at regular Dave and for your
gaming news stay tuned to games.com